let's just bring you some breaking news
that's just coming into us and UK Health
security agencies there's a pupil at a
school in Sussex who's suspected to have
had an invasive strep a infection has
died the pupil whose age and gender were
not given had attended Hove Park School
and Specialists from the UK HSA are
working with Brighton and Hove city
council to support the school following
the death and we have had a statement
from one of the Consultants Dr Rachel
hornigood who's a consultant in health
protection at the UK HSA and she said we
are extremely saddened to hear about the
death of a young child and our thoughts
are with their family friends and the
local community infection of group a
Streptococcus bacterium usually causes a
sore throat scarlet fever or skin rash
and is passed by physical contact or
through droplets from sneezing or
coughing in very rare cases the
infection can become invasive and enter
parts of the body where bacteria aren't
normally found which can be serious we
will Implement Public Health actions
including advice to the city council and
school community so that is the latest
that's just coming into us now that a
pupil at a school in Sussex who
suspected to have had invasive strep a
infection has died the age or gender of
that pupil has not yet been provided to
us but we do know that they attended a
school called Hove Park School and this
brings the number of children who've
died from strep a since September to 16.